and the pure manifestation of that is a
[__] New World Warrior it's one that
decentralizes basic needs
infrastructures and freeze people it's
one that fights to end the wars that are
happening around the world to bring
peace around the world it's one that
frees people of matrix enslavements it's
not one that says that oh it doesn't
matter because everything is already
perfect that's a bypass that's a
repression
because inside is an angry spiritual
[__] that actually wants to unleash
itself an angry Warrior that wants to
unleash
[Music]
itself
so you like masturbating on your sense
of
self you like masturbating on
Concepts especially spiritual
ones you non-u
[__] you like talking about
Oneness but you don't like taking
action you don't like like rage you
don't like anger you don't like
fully letting go of everything that's
being repressed so you can actually be a
warrior for the new
world all of that's repressed by you
being a spiritual
[__] by your sense of
self and sometimes you need a military
General to tell you that you're being a
repressed [__] and and that you're
tripping on some sort of nothingness or
emptiness or nonduality or everything or
what is or whatever that is just a not
ground it is not a ground and actually
what it is is it's a repressing of what
your unique gift is in service to Earth
in service to
others this is the [__] stage this is
the [__] Battleground [__]
and you're repressing you're pretending
like you're not actually a unique
character that is on the battleground of
Earth you
are and what are you choosing to
build and what are where are you
building
from
nonduality is where everything always
comes from everything is always not
separate everything is always nothing
everything everything's always that
and the pure manifestation of that is a
[__] New World Warrior it's one that
decentralizes basic needs
infrastructures and freeze people it's
one that fights to end the wars that are
happening around the world to bring
peace around the
world it's one that frees people of
matrix enslavements it's not one that
says that oh it doesn't matter because
everything is already
perfect that's a bypass that's a
repression because inside is an angry
spiritual [__] that actually wants to
unleash itself an angry Warrior that
wants to unleash
itself and the spiritual [__] is the one
that's repressing the
warrior spirituality is drunk on
equinity
it's drunk on Stillness as a ground it's
drunk on emptiness that is a
ground meanwhile there's no difference
between the still and empty Buddha or
the
Raging alcoholics at bars or at
tailgates at sporting events there's no
difference at all so [__] your stupid
little ground of being an empty Buddha
that's sitting in Stillness tast the
emptiness that you are the everything
that you are and then integrate it into
your [__] body into your [__] mask
and into your godamn role in gifts on
New
Earth you're now in the straight jacket
of being a spiritual
[__] there's no difference between being
in the straight jacket of separation and
being in the straight jacket of being
spiritual [__] or being identified
spiritually or being identif ified as
Oneness or non-duality or a spiritual
teacher or one that teaches a certain
tool set it's all complete straight
jacket the only thing that's not
straight jacket is tasting the
nonseparation that always already is
obvious and then fully integrating that
into your mask into your costume into
your body and being the Sky Warrior on
Earth for basic needs
for New Earth abundance and prosperity
for all stop avoiding that [__]
stop avoiding
that stop watching equanimous spiritual
[__] that are sitting on Royal
philosopher chairs with flowers on the
side and instead why don't you get on
the goddamn Battlefield p and [__]
knock out some
[__] knock out the Matrix enslavement
technology techologies and systems knock
those out free people of them increase
awareness of them build new systems that
transcend
those stop masturbating on infinite
Consciousness as a [__] concept as an
audience member and seeker of a holy
Guru that you're licking the ball sack
of and I mean now I mean
constitutionalize the [__] body right
now as new Earth as empty everythingness
being the character that that body
uniquely is and its gifts and bringing
those
constitutionalize as bringing those
gifts to service in service to Earth in
service to others in service to the
whole stop repressing them stop
repressing your emotions stop repressing
your thoughts stop repressing your
honest self stop repressing
that
and that means unstraight jacket
everything let everything flow have
complete transparency with absolutely
nothing hidden zero
hidden with your family with your
friends with everyone with the internet
with everyone have nothing hidden
nothing hidden at all be a completely
transparent
body and soldier on the
battlefield saying exactly what is the
constitution of the body which is basic
needs abundance for all and get going on
building those communities get going on
building those infrastructures get going
on supporting the ones that are exiting
and building go and Homestead yourself
exit out of the old and build into the
new stop masturbating on spirituality
stop masturbating on spirituality stop
masturbating on spirituality stop
masturbating on non-duality stop
masturbating on non-duality nonduality
is not a ground it is not a ground my
friend die into your [__] character
you godamn Soldier die into your [__]
character's role in serving your unique
gifts to the
collective you [__] repressed [__]
how often have you shown your [__]
nipples to the
internet especially the male bodies how
often have you shown your nipples to the
internet look at this Natural Body this
Natural Animal body absorbing all of the
sunlight sitting on the grass taking the
grass eating the
grass taste the Earth be the Earth seize
the war seize the central ization of
nation states sees this centralization
of centralized Bank digital
currencies a centralization of all of
the control systems the propaganda
machines CES being a slave to that CES
being asleep to that sees tripping out
in nonduality and what is n sees that
that is not a [__] ground [__] die
into your godamn character die die into
it go out with a [__] sword and chop
off the heads of the Matrix control
system and build the goddamn new
Earth if you don't masturbate to the
solar Punk style of futurism of Earth in
complete harmony with nature and
abundance for all get going start
looking at that every single day that is
the indigenous Earthly wisdom brought
together with modern technology and
prosperity for all that is the archetype
that is what we're working
with constitutionalize yourself as
that stop sing to Mommy and Daddy stop
sing to the government stop sing to
Instagram girls and only fan and PornHub
stop in stop sing
to
[__] clout
chasing objectification of all
sort I will be whole when I get this
object when I get this spiritual concept
when I get validated cease all of that
you are already whole you are a [__]
military General
already now take that military General
eneral and start rallying the [__]
troops around you to build the [__]
new Earth stop masturbating on scrolling
on pointless social
media get [__] grounded get [__]
grounded build the free energy systems
themselves build
them build
them
talk about them like a [__] drum is
beating free and nergy free energy free
energy build new Earth build new Earth
build new Earth build new Earth rally
the troops rally the
troops build new Earth build new Earth
build new Earth build new Earth build
new Earth constitutionalize as that and
never [__] budge from
it don't be ashamed to your Incarnation
don't be ashamed to your
Incarnation don't repress your [__]
gifts that you came here to express
[__] you came here with unique
codes with unique gift to express to
this Collective as this this infinite as
this infinite ody expressing gifts as
this [__] endless sunlight expressing
gifts to this Collective Now [__]
Express
them and stop waiting for a goddamn
permission slip like this [__]
video cease it cease it completely the
sovereignty the constitutionalization in
the body body and be unshakable and
never [__] move from
it you came here to die on that [__]
sword so die on
it surrender all of the
body to the perfect
flow channeling through the empty vessel
for abundance and prosperity on Earth
only and only
that the Stillness and non-separation is
already a given it is not something that
must be attained over eons of work it is
already the infinitude it is already it
it is already it so therefore there is
only the character there is only the
body there is only Infinity being the
body the character so be the [__]
gifts of that character you went through
so much
contraction and then
expansion so [__] be the gifts be the
gifts as these words flow out the body
these these tight muscles loosen these
nerves loosen because it is
felt that the truth is Flowing the
contractions are loosening the body is
becoming more of an effortless waterfall
of what it is meant to
be quit being so goddamn boring and
predictable you [__] boring
predictable spiritual
[__] I want you to be a [__] Warrior
I want you to be a general I want you to
rally the troops and build the new
Earth daddy keep all the way up there I
want you to only talk about the solar
Punk future I want you to only build
that come on Daddy only talk about free
energy only talk about the traps
avoiding the traps of the Matrix control
system and the way Awakening those that
are still asleep to it liberating them
from that exiting that and building the
new communities the new homesteads the
new water food energy housing
sovereignty Joy basic needs
peace creativity science engineering art
children being free children growing up
and being
free nonduality does not care at all
about children growing up in being free
nonduality must be integrated into the
gifts of the body that then roar like
the
divine feminine and masculine gifts that
can come through it so
that that new Earth can actually be
manifest there is no ground called
emptiness that is literally the same
thing as the body as the costume as the
mask as the Warfield as the battlefield
as the [__] stage and the actors
themselves so it's already [__] done
now go and godamn build the new Earth
build
it constitutionalize yourself as it and
never [__]
move and dare I say be a top G
[__]
[Music]
sh
that's